and one thing that helps comedians keep
perspective is like
bombing on stage and i ask every
comedian on here like a story of getting
booed or like just an
unforgettable show that was just
everything went wrong
right like do you have one top of mind
and this is how crazy
it happens for me okay that's how unique
i am as a human being my first show
i used to do the open mic night at the
greensboro comedy zone every first and
second thursday of the month right
so i went the first thursday because i
never
been to a comedy club before this point
like i didn't grow up thinking i'm gonna
be a comedian that was not
at all it wasn't my in my goals
until i started you're gonna be a
cameraman right no i was gonna be a news
agent or a news anchor yeah
yeah when i was in college i thought i
was gonna be a news anchor when i was
young i thought i was just gonna be a
rich
dope dylan street [ __ ] okay
that was it i thought that was what you
wanted to do until my uncle got murdered
and i was like oh
yeah this ain't it because he was 100
times tougher than i can ever be and i
knew that
and i said well if that's what his fate
was oh i know what they got for me
now i want to have to do that because i
was trained by these people so i know
the reality of being out there in that
environment
is you know you hear people say it all
the time you go deaf or jail
but the reality is death or jail
like when you see death in jail
right next to you it has a different
type of feeling
than it does when people just saying it
to you because if you never experienced
it you don't know what it feel like
to have to view a body
or to have to you know
smell a person clothes that's gone
forever you know i mean those little
nuances that people don't recognize
but once i got on stage
at the second open mic night was the
second week after i went to the first
show
four minutes killed in my mind which i
know now
being in the game you can't really kill
in four minutes but in that four minutes
i smash
so at that point i'm in it the very next
open mic night
the month after which is september
i went up with the confidence of richard
pryor chappelle [ __ ] i'm talking about
it was
you couldn't tell me that i wasn't d.l
bernie harvey i'm talking about i was
everybody i got on stage
and ate uh mean
i'm talking about it was me and for some
reason wasn't it was probably like i say
40 50 people at the first open mic that
i did this one was packed
all white people and i got on stage
talking some [ __ ] and they was just like
and this is the thing booing
is different because boom means you've
affected the people some type of way
that means you invoke some type of
emotion to it boo
[ __ ] you [ __ ] but when that
silence
that means that they don't have a clue
how to feel about what you're doing up
there
and that silence is nasty it's two types
of silences and comedy that i've learned
at least in my experience is the silence
of
what's next what is he gonna say next
that quiet that comes over the room so
they can hear
everything that you're saying and then
it's that quiet of
who's next what's next and who's next
i was in the who's next that i mean they
just was like
hey hot brother and sister if you love
comedy as much as we do here at hot
breath
click the subscribe button to join the
hot breath verse and then watch more
videos to get even more comedy tips